coming up next the same mistake and I
will make the same mistake and blame it
on them in my feminine energy men always
stare and approach me I will be
submissive for the right man men are
trash equals I take no accountability
for the negative don't objectify me but
a lot of times we objectify ourselves
the way we dress the way we present I
don't deal with f boys so like women who
who protect their box they're not
dealing with that energy partner
horoscope signs I'm looking for a
connection energy trauma toxic
masculinity my truth healing
narcissistic ex-boyfriend abusive
ex-boyfriend great accusation with no
evidence don't judge yeah but
manifesting equals I want to do no work
and get the outcome as a woman I did too
much and I let him walk all over me
equals I like cheaters and toxic men and
I will choose them and be toxic as well
and not admit that I had any part to
play except hashtag giving too much
generational trauma I make the same
mistakes that my parents made and I'm
too dumb to learn from their mistakes
and instead I will blame the same
mistake and I will make the same mistake
and blame it on them in my feminine
energy men always stare and approach me
I will be submissive for the right man
men are trash equals I take no
accountability for the negative part
that myself or any woman play in
relationships he needs to make six
figures equals I have no emphasis on
character I don't need a man but I want
a man my ring needs to cost this much
Financial abuse
um I became feminine I need a man to
maintain you we need to Vibe I feel like
I'm traditional
um when I have done no work to become
traditional Manish I will be submissive
for the right man who hurt you
internalize misogyny I am leveling up
together I need a man to be on my level
level Boss B I'm a bad these men
are broken dusties
he needs to add to what I have going on
in my life not all women equals that is
a problem with women but I won't admit
it's a problem
um I need someone to match my energy I
am his peace
I read it better than I read the super
chats because I've spent a lot of time
writing that sometimes you wrote it and
because of the letters people spell
things wrong in the Super Chat okay
because they don't you only get so many
characters so you're kind of making out
what they say anyways you should have
had a cocky for that you know like start
the clock somebody yeah yeah anyway so
what what did I get wrong I didn't hear
astrological signs in there
[Music]
anything okay
okay yeah go ahead add the one we have
to add is broken men because women are
broken too but it's more pain I'm sorry
man this is calling you out
like I said this panel to show you that
you actually were broken and I just want
to say women say men are F boys but how
do you know he's a f boy if you didn't
let him F yes so does that make you a f
girl does it make you easy does it make
you for the street you don't want a man
to save you for the street but you can
call him an F boy I don't deal with f
boys so like women who who protect their
box they're not dealing with that energy
but if you've been effed and ran through
you have to say to yourself I've allowed
this man to be a f boy to my most
precious my most precious possession on
The Dating Market which is my womb my
body and it we say you know my body my
choice and don't objectify me but a lot
of times we objectify ourselves the way
we dress the way we present and then we
we blame a man but like I never heard
the term F boy until I start getting on
Tick Tock and I dealt in these spaces
and I'm like well why did you let him
hunch on you
they need to say that
[Music]
[Laughter]
he hit me harder than I hit him oh damn
it's still a hit what about body
positivity like is that sort of mainly
for a specific body or is that it's only
for women it's only for women where
where have you seen a 300 pound man on
the front of Cosmo or any other magazine
it's only for women and and you will see
the same women who will put down men or
shame them for their height but where's
your body positivity for a man who's
five feet tall but you want a man to
accept you as you are except him as he
is but see it's it's not equal
broke man positivity yes ma'am
listen listen I want to talk about this
as well and I know like you know uh the
guys actually it was only one other one
of the guy here but you know from from
my perspective
um
like you know as a as a young boy right
like and you're watching these shows on
TV where they're talking about a man uh
a man's member the size matter like how
dare you how how how the nerve of you
cowards to get up on TV and to talk
about on daytime talk show TV and to
talk about the size matter does your
viscous in this matter yeah because
because
y'all are just as different with your
insides as we are different with our
outsides so y'all could judge all this
ever in terms of size depth
circumference where it's actually
positioned
small dick energy
because we talk about the pH we talk
about the smell and some of that is from
a genetic perspective as well but like
the the actual oil on the inside of it
like it's it's a lot different as well
so like if it doesn't go right it
doesn't all have to do with his member
you know but to talk about that it
happens young boys listening to that
sometimes maybe because it's damaging
maybe that's what it is because the
women always say that the man's dick is
too small but the women ever say my fan
is too big
is the body's positivity they will claim
the same body positivity I can be 500
pounds and accept me as I am but the
same woman will claim small D energy was
something that's genetic where if you
controlled how much you ate
and you exercise and discipline yourself
you can actually control doesn't mean to
be a supermodel in a size you know I
don't know in the UK with the sizes are
but like size two and zero like super
skinny but a lot of men aren't even
looking for that but you will claim body
positivity but the same woman will say
you got small D energy I'm not even
talking about that I'm talking about a
woman I'm on my mother always say oh he
didn't satisfy me because dick small but
you never had a man say a funny was too
big I was rolling around in it
oh there was so much air rushing around
yeah you know yeah
I have a really great um addition to
this list thank you thank you to Bose
nuts um
my ex was a narcissist yeah you just
fell for that yeah
I've always okay this is what I've come
to conclude I've come to conclude this
okay wait wait wait I need I need to get
this off my chest okay I have come to
conclude that either 50 of all men are
narcissists or women are all dating the
same narcissists or maybe women are the
problem no just so scientifically has
been shown uh this is the research so
let's get into data and not just waiting
okay you gotta add I'm a queen oh please
add that one independent
is it qw
spelling it
okay what's the date um disagree about
something right now like everyone sort
of agreeing with a lot of things
and I feel like I need to disagree about
some a few things actually a few things
on that list I personally remove I don't
know exactly what but one stood out to
me now I've had a few exes
a lot of the exes I've had I've been
very very nice men
I I'd say recently I'd say about in
October I got out of a relationship and
I was with this guy for a year
and this guy was genuinely abusive does
that mean I cannot use the term like I
had an abusive ex does that mean that I
like should diminish my sort of feelings
because of that because genuinely I had
to go through like victim support and
things like that I had to put things in
place for my safety so as a woman do you
think that I should not use that because
I know you are laughing and joking and
what not about like narcissism obviously
I know there's only a small percentage
of men that are actually narcissistic
and I think people that ruin it is the
women that fold these words out like for
example women that lie about getting
raped or women that lie about getting a
like sexually assaulted they ruin it
let's say sorry I say they ruin it for
the actual women that have been victim
and I know again I'm one of those people
that believe in accountability I
genuinely believe that you should take
accountability for the things that have
happened to you and you should fix
yourself but I just don't think it's
fair to say that you have you should
should diminish your own experience
because other women want to throw out
the words or the phrases and
again it sort of brings it down to
yourself
um thank you it sort of just brings it
down to the fact that it makes you feel
a bit worse about it sort of thing
because again I've been through things
and again I can say maybe I've not been
the perfect person maybe some other
things I've done are my fault but that
does not diminish my experience of the
things that I have had happened to me
yeah can I just say yeah no from a woman
that's I'm going to speak a normal
that's been abused right in my day you
call the police nothing happened in your
day you get all the things out there
you've got victim support I never read
it so why are you staying in it I've got
no sympathy for people nowadays I went
through so you went you went for an
abusive relationship you know what I
don't give a if a man was going
through a relationship actually
I can say the same thing I can say the
same thing I can say the same you can
say the same thing I've got a child out
of it you've got a child I'm 21.
right you call the police if you call
the police what happens to you because
the police don't want to do sympathy
because I'm concerned you're in an
abusive relationship
nowadays they've got everything there
you can walk out but do you not
understand people can genuinely
manipulate you as somebody that's not
grown up with the best minutes
you were young right as someone that's
not grown up you're the best Role Models
sorry it's hard for you to just click on
your own immediately what were your role
models
all I'm going to say is that you said
you were young I was young you said you
abused I was abused you then called the
police right because in my day I called
the police and nothing happened because
they were saying it was a domestic right
so we're here talking about stuff and
you're going to go against everything
I'm not going against something
these things happen no no no okay no
pearls just brought up a list of words
like women but he's saying that you
cannot use
the words don't stick on them
get ways use and you've come up and
you're using the same thing again to
reiterate my point I clearly said to you
yeah I am a woman that believes in
taking accountability and the woman
that's healing I am a 21 year old girl
I'm not necessarily as matured as you
lot or I'm not necessarily as
experienced as you're not a girl you're
a grown woman
relationship don't use the word girl
because you will say and I don't mean
this to put you down listen my mother
was raped it for it sorry sorry great at
14.
with um a weapon to her
her mother she was raised in section
eight I don't know if you have that over
here welfare yeah okay she had no father
at home she didn't meet her father until
she was pregnant with me at 30 at his
funeral when he was in a casket
everything you talk about people have
went through worse and it's not to
diminish what you've gone through
what you've gone through is a Learning
lesson for you to do better like my
mother then went on and did better than
her family through horrible
circumstances who took her in were nuns
Catholic nuns when her mother kicked her
out
from being assaulted at 14 and pregnant
that's how I have my oldest sister
so what I'm saying to you what you went
through use it as a learning lesson use
it to feel who you want to be in the
future
and realize the world has no sympathy
for any of us the only person who cares
about us the most is yourself
and you you use that as a learning
lesson to never let someone manipulate
you this is the issue that we have a lot
of times women will say I was a victim
of this and you were
okay it's not nobody doesn't believe you
or anything like that absolutely we know
the trauma and even their psychological
um I I would say things that can someone
can do to you that can break you down we
even talk about Stockholm syndrome and
all these these things are very real in
psychology
but what you have to say now and say out
of all that list she said you have to
say you know
how can I now
learn that lesson so that I no longer
can be a victim to such a monster I
don't say and and you have to say take
accountability and say how am I choosing
and do I have am I purposely choosing
women in my life to guide me am I coming
under discipline and Leadership have I
made changes are there were there people
in my life that said this is not a good
guy but I still chose to be with this
person or I saw the red flags and it's
not to point blame we all make mistakes
every single person in this room has not
lived a perfect life so it's not about
um
um saying that you it was somehow your
fault you're very young
but now what happens is a lot of you
guys are very young but the world now
sees you you use the word girl and the
reason why I said you're a woman is that
now the world is going to hold you
accountable as a woman and you're going
to be a mother you're going to be
somebody's grandmother you're going to
be everything you've gone through is a
lesson and so what you want to do for
your life now is take what has happened
digest it and accountability looks like
this
why did I choose that what didn't my my
family of origin not give me
after that situation have I sought out
the counseling the help that I need am I
surrounding myself with people that you
know that I can learn from so that I can
do better what I find a lot of times is
a lot of times we'll be victimized and
we'll go through things and then we'll
wall out we'll go off because
emotionally we don't know how to deal
with the situation
and and I think what the point is is
nobody here wants you to be a victim
ever again we want you to have strength
and we want your daughters we want your
family we want you to have a husband we
want you to be taken care of we want you
to be loved on in a way that you may not
have experienced but in order to get
that you know what happens to a lot of
women who have been through that
situation you continue to attract that
same man so unless you pause on dating
pause or you're very young you don't
even need to date right now
and do the internal work reading books
how many books or relationships have you
read how many things have you have you
done to work on your healing through
therapy if you can't afford therapy I
think in the UK this stuff is free and
the U.S has a struggle bus but you know
because we have to pay for everything
but like have you explored every Avenue
because you say you know what I have to
care about me more than anyone else and
I can never allow another person so when
I happened to my mother what she did is
those nuns took her and she had no one
and I won't go into details of
um how horrific it was but imagine being
violated as that as a child and being
pregnant and then your own mother who
was for the streets had children by
different men competed against you for
different men did not believe you and
didn't want another mouth to feed and
kicked you out in that situation
my she just tried to find what she could
and those nuns helped her she got her
GED in the U.S that's like your high
school diploma and then she said she
didn't talk to her family for seven
years she said I'm gonna do better than
all of them she joined the military in
the U.S became ROTC she went to college
graduated I grew up in the Pentagon
under Colin Powell and people in the U.S
you guys may not know who these people
are but um I interned at the White House
and I she raised me in private school
she got married my father and had me and
it was a lot going on so I only want to
say this to you Pearl is not bringing
this up to re-victimize you because it's
very serious but don't take it as a
criticism yeah but if we don't say it to
you A lot of times you will still be
attracted to whatever energy and and I
believe in spirituality whatever Spirit
you were attracted to you will continue
to attract that unless you say you know
what what was in me that I saw red flags
in this man and I stayed why you know
and and how can I heal and grow from
this so I can do better and get better
nobody's putting you down we want you to
heal and I and I I want you to
understand that that we understand and
we absolutely do not blame you you're
very young but I can see you going far
if you can take the accountability and
heal and do and make better choices in
men because they don't deserve you a
demon like that who would abuse you does
not deserve you and we don't want you to
be attracted to that same Spirit again
but you're right in saying that because
again I know I just went a bit berserk
about the words but I think about in
saying what you do say manifests in
itself so like if I am saying he saw
words then again it can happen again and
sort of thing because I like you said
I'm attracting that sort of energy but
yeah um I really appreciate what you
just said and I definitely do agree with
it I just think sometimes people can be
a bit harsh in the way that they sort of
say things
so straightforward but man that's where
I am I'm not apologizing no no you're
fine
yeah currently still how
I'm going
um
two months I don't know is it a male or
female therapist female female
and I just tend not to really like I
speak about it but I just don't really
think it's helping can I tell you that
I'm the men in the space like MTR and
there's other men in the space this is
one thing Kevin Samuels was a good
friend of mine and a lot of women were
upset with him
um because he would speak harshly and
but one of the things that he understood
is a lot of women that had no leadership
and guidance and Direction ahead you
know they were lied to their entire
lives they've been victimized by men in
a very um harsh way he was very harsh
with men in fact she this just went
viral women are just discovering how he
went crazy on men like way harder than
women
and
um and I talked he one of the things he
said was that like no one's talking to
them people are just allowing our women
to be victimized and and and and and
telling them what they want to hear so
one of the things I would advise you to
do is to listen to men like MTR there's
a lot of men in the space
that if you actually listen to them
befriended men in that space they would
give you protection
and especially if you come with a humble
spirit and you're listening and you will
learn from them how men think and you
will start to see wait I've seen a man
like MTR who is talking about high
achieving and and this that and the
other and and what the expectations are
and you start to see when a guy comes
across you again who's like basic and
and you could start to see those red
flags because you're just like I've seen
other men who are not this way who are
you know who are who are different who
speak different you may not been exposed
to it so if a man comes with you with
the same red flag energy that could
victimize you you'll know better you
won't even be attracted to anymore
because you have that exposure and as
you befriend these men instead of making
a lot of women make them their enemy but
a lot of these men will will love you
and give you advice and and treat you
with respect and if you brought a man in
a direction and ask them advice they
would be happy to tell you the truth
about that man but this is the thing a
lot of women will hear the truth we will
notice those red flags from our family
and friends or we know in our spirit but
we're attracted to something but we're
not willing to step away we there's a
little bit of rebellion in US If we're
honest we want what we want I'm grown
I'm gonna make my own choice but as you
grow and as you get older these are
things are going to be important because
you're going to tell your daughters or
your children the same thing or you may
raise your sons to never victimize a
woman you got to know what that looks
like
um
I was going to say something but it's
just absolutely gone out my head um I
just feel like me personally I've been
disadvantaged a bit growing up because
I've never really felt like I have been
protected by a man
um again I'm not trying to you
a father I do but he's just very like
distant
um I've never really like had like did
he not grow up with you separate
um so he I lived with him in a split
family from probably about 10 years old
but he's he came from uh Sierra Leone
and he didn't he didn't speak very well
English you don't know much about like
the Western culture and whatnot he was
just very again emotionally distant he
was a bit strict but like he never
really taught me core values or like
what to see in a man he was a little bit
abusive as well which is I think one of
the reasons why I don't I wouldn't say I
seek abusive men but I don't originally
now I've started looking into it I spot
the signs but originally I'd be around
either emotionally unavailable men or
men that are
abusive so I feel like I had a bit of
disadvantage at that point like you were
saying earlier like with the whole when
you grow up
um
be involved to be a housewife I'd never
really got that so I feel like I've been
disadvantaged in that sense but it's
something that I'm currently working on
and something that like obviously I'm
currently healing myself before I get
into another relationship because I
don't want to hurt myself again with a
man that I feel does not deserve me
um but again I just feel like I said
earlier a bit disadvantaged in that
sense but it's something that I I need
to and you said you were and you don't
have to talk about this if you don't
want to so feel free to not answer any
of this but you you said um you were 17.
um how did you meet him fubuck through
work and did you did he know you before
that
um yeah from what age like 15. oh wow
yeah
was he like a boss or something no he
just what's up man work
um MTR you understand yeah this is a
type of conversation that um I typically
I think it's very important for the
women to talk to the women regarding
this conversation
um I kind of feel like I got a place
without a turn in order to enter
information but let me give you from my
perspective of something that I tell the
men on my channel is that
when you're vetting a young woman
one of the first places that you should
look at is the relationship between her
father
and you mentioned that you said that
your father was abusive
and one thing that we actually learn in
the conversation earlier today is like
like attracts like and if your father
was abusive you are more likely to
attract abuse going into the future and
I think that it Reigns true even within
this conversation I think there was a
lot of points that were made on both
sides of the coin from both Melanie and
Auntie Jenny that I think
um you should replay this video back at
the end of the day
um you have to be responsible for you
and
what you don't want to do is be a victim
into your singleness yeah into until
you're lonely forever and can I say this
you know it's a failure of us as older
women
that we should be
um you know being able to Mentor young
women who have gone through these things
and being able to be a voice so many
older women are competing they're taking
the same thirst trapping photos and
still doing the most only care about
themselves they don't care about their
children they're looking for what's best
for them but I think I'm 41 you're 21
we're 20 years apart and I was blessed
where my like my my sister and cousin
flew out with me like on a dime because
our father our you know our families
raised us where they have money we were
able to do what we want we're black
Americans which is it's very rare like
on I was like hey I gotta be file for
business I want to go hey girl let's go
like my sister bought a travel agency
just so we could travel and like get
discounts like like we're in those
positions and I say my sister is one of
the people who's mentored me like like
just talking to her but by family in
general and I think you know if you want
to hit me up and this is how I was
raised because my parents did a lot of
church ministry and things but if you
want to hit up and you want to talk to
an older woman who's not likely I'm not
your mother I'm not gonna you know but
if you wanna you know you know just you
know like hey can I
I I don't know certain things and I
think that we as older women have failed
this generation of women the younger
women and
um and we take I take accountability for
that not you know me specifically that
I've done it but in general and even
your mother allowing you to be raised by
a man who victimized you and did not
raise you you know in the way that you
should go but you can change that and
you can have a great outcome don't let
this Define you let it be just a lesson
to make greater you know say pain always
leaves a gift
[Music]
Auntie's been holding up her hand I'm
trying to be good just because you're
here right that's because you're ahead
that's what holds it up behind no button
now I'm on purpose no um
um Melanie
um as older woman and I'm older than you
the young people don't want to listen
we're old school so I'm sorry about I
don't take that I understand what you're
saying and from your point if you agree
I'm tired of talking to young people
because they don't want to listen so I'm
not going to nice it up Pearl knows EPO
wants advice and she can't get hold of
her mother purple for me I'm gonna nice
it out for pill I would tell her
straight that tree Pearl I will tell two
o'clock in the morning I'm gonna tell
her like it is I don't give a damn how
she takes it you ask me a question I'm
gonna give you an answer I don't want to
go around and I've been talking to young
people all I've been Auntie Jenny now
for 37 years I've been Auntie Jenny
Auntie Jenny's not a new thing I've got
the I've got the young people now coming
telling me Oh you know what you tell
them on your podcast you told me that
when I was young yeah I did and you know
what I've got to the point now where cut
the crap yeah you're going out there
you're adults things have changed now
things have moved on so much you're on
Instagram you're on Tick Tock you're on
this you're on that you got your Android
you're making your money and I'm
supposed to feel sorry because you buy
the bad life I've had a bad life you
know if it was a man that would say man
up yep now woman up I don't give a task
fruit because you know that you're in
the UK now there's free therapy I've had
it the first one didn't work are the
second one or the third one I tried all
different kinds until it worked so
that's why I got to the point where I am
where I don't wanna I don't want to hear
no excuses for the UK because in the UK
they laid down they will lie down
backwards to help you
you want therapy it's there whatever
kind you want is there your ill is there
everything is free in the UK education
everything is free so I can understand
what you're saying for the American
point of view but from England I take no
excuses I'm tired of talking to young
people because they will look at me and
they would say ah this is what I've been
told it's changed now your old school
things are different but you know what
you think things are different but deep
inside the body the foundation of life
is still there it's been going on and on
and on so I'm tired of talking to young
people in a way that oh yeah let me be
nice yeah let me soothe it for you no if
it was a man if a man come to you and
they said oh I'm feeling a bit depressed
you say come on
so I've got to the point where if it's
good enough for the goose it's good
enough for the gander I've taken no
prisoners no excuses if a man can man up
a woman can man up it's there for you so
I ain't got no excuses you know what
because I'm the exception that nothing
that she ain't been through that I've
been through 10 times worse she was
lucky she come out of it without a child
I come out of it 17 years old with a
child hey you know what one child I've
still got 37 years old and you know what
everybody looked down at me I didn't
take no excuses I was in a basic abusive
relationship when I had my son I'll go
out of it less than a year I got out of
it with a child I was on contraception
because I'm an exception to every rule
so if I can do it I'm putting up a notes
you ask me for advice I'm going to give
it to you if you don't like it piss off
no and I that's my view you're a
frustration
the fact that we're going over the same
things over and over and over and over
and over again trying to make it nice
for the young modern women life ain't
nice friends life ain't nice life is
character building whatever happens to
you spin it on his head and make it
build you make it make you a stronger
person this help out there go and get it
everywhere you go in England now you
watch yourself in England
that is something the other day about
men because they now decide that men's
mental health matters at the end of
every sub and every English person will
tell you there's a phone number if this
has affected you or you have something
similar phone this number you will get
help that is in England so because all
the helpers out there I don't want to
hear it it's no I understand
they want to watch the doordash
they digest toxicity and one of the
things I would say Aunt Jenny you're
correct because one of the things I
would say and you guys have got to
understand her perspective and don't
take it as though she's been harsh or
whatever like we live in a very soft
generation like if you I don't know how
it was it I do know I was in the UK but
if you understand what people went
through in the U.S I always bring up
Meghan Markle compared to Ruby Bridges
Megan Mark they're going in the
worldwide privacy tour complaining uh I
lived in the castle my brother got the
biggest size of the room and all this
other stuff I I came my first time in
the UK was to go to to that wedding
because I was proud of the situation and
I thought it was something great but as
I started to see the complaining I said
Ruby Bridges in the U.S there was
segregation between black and white
people in schools Ruby Bridges was
seven-year-old little girl she was the
first black girl to ever go into a white
school in the entire U.S if you look
back at the documentaries what she went
through black people particularly in the
U.S during segregation she stood what we
call ten toes down harder than Meghan
Markle because some precedent like her
there was a little girl who stood harder
and you've never heard Ruby Bridges say
a word okay you Rosa Parks you know
people who went through real oppression
but it's it can be the victim Olympics
every person everything that you went
through Somebody went through
a thousand times worse if you look
through history but this is the thing
this is the thing it is a failure right
now because many of us we're so much
into our feelings my truth what is about
me it is such a self-indulgent culture
we don't care about the family it's
about me what my body my choice so you
can't save my body my choice but yet I
was victimized by a man so like is it
you you want sympathy to say well I was
victimized but hey it was your body your
choice so there are these these opposing
things the only thing I say is that if
we can if we can come to I feel like not
everyone's going to change I I go with
the 10 I go with there are people who
will stay hard-headed stay in Rebellion
stay in Pride and want what they want
lust greed and whatever and you're going
to get the results of that but if I can
if what you just said what I said the
combination of these things if we can
like talk to these young women and say I
understand let me like maybe Mentor you
I still think there's a responsibility
of us as older women's and Mentor now if
you have a mentee that's hard-headed and
will still want to run the streets still
making the same choice you got to go
you're going to face those consequences
I don't hear but I will tell you there
are women like my mother who it wasn't
her choice it wasn't her fault she made
a choice she decided to change she
listened to these nuns after she was
thrown out if you continue to be
hard-headed you have to understand life
is going to throw you horrific
consequences if you don't listen to a
woman like Aunt Jenny you think she's
just popping off and she don't
understand if you don't take the time to
understand you want to be you you want
Direction you don't let her guide you
because you don't like the tone this is
what Kevin Samuels he was a friend of
mine they ain't like his tone but now
all of a sudden they do because they
realize they're not getting the results
and the same thing that you're saying
they don't like your tone but you're fed
up because you'll give them you've given
the soft tone you've tried everything
and they don't want to listen so y'all
have to understand there's two sides to
this coin and I just said when my
frustrations come from like you're
guiding about going back to history I
was 12 years old and I come to England I
was a English woman went to Barbados
come back go back to the Jungle you know
so it all happened I was 12 years old
um what I don't what I felt Paul can say
pearl knows some of the women that I
come that come on this show and I blast
them I give them my personal number
to say well you know if you want to
change help me
and then I've got the men on Instagram
that I mentor on Instagram who
regular the man I have never had 100
year old girl with my therapy practice
before men I gave him my number I've had
numerous people on this show women young
girls
on the 21 I've tried to help and do they
take it now because she's old school but
yet the men the men that I talk to or
the men that hear me they'll find me up
oh aren't you Jenny can you give me some
help can you advise me I have had the
men phone up the show and then I've said
now you're fat just like that you're fat
and you know to the gym and the guys
will come back and they'll show me one
guy came back and I looked him and I
thought do I recognize you well guess
what
he got himself a girlfriend and he was
doing great but the girls
fantasy men can't be forever victims
because nobody cares about nobody cares
about their problems nobody cares about
Johnny Depp to me about their problems
and they changed they take the advice
from me but the women don't well because
the hardest thing to do is change
yourself you have to live with yourself
every day and and Men actually look to
solve problems or what women just look
to feel better most of the time yeah I
mean yeah
[Music]
but he's um that's the way it's spelled
but he's he's not no I have the men
phoning me up on my Instagram but the
women never phone up you sit here and
you say the same things over and over
again you try and give them help and
then they walk out of them it's like ah
she didn't know nothing but can I say
this to you if you hit me up my my
Instagram I'll give it to you okay if
you want to talk I promise you no it's
my responsibility and and no no don't
feel like you're bothering me it's my
job God is didn't put me on this Earth
just to you know for myself why do you
think
because
I don't know I I just I don't know the
way my mother raised me my my father
raised me I I don't want you to feel
alone you know in a lot of young women
don't have someone to say something
directly to them but this is the thing
I'm gonna tell you just like on Jenny
just said if you are I can listen to
another opinion I can listen to if you
feel something different but if I feel
like you're bucking and you're like
gonna be rebellious and you're still
making choices with the same and if I
tell you listen these are red flags you
gotta stop I do this now my father's my
best friend my sister they will tell me
automatically I'm like MTR will tell you
I'm scared of my sister
okay like I'm terrified of her because
she loves me so much she wants the best
for me she's doing so much improving but
I know if she's given me instruction and
I've stepped out
oh I'm gonna get it I'm good she is
going to read me and I'm like terrified
of it but it's a good terrified because
I know she loves you she wants the best
for me and she could see me being if I'm
being hard-headed same thing with my
father so you have to understand if you
reach out for help be prepared to
receive that help in the way that it
comes it's not going to come always in a
pretty package and it's not going to be
what you want to hear but if you have a
soft heart and a willing you you have a
will your ears are willing to listen to
digest doesn't mean you have to be
perfect but if you're gonna you know so
many women they they rebel against older
women they think well I'm young she's
old she don't know any better and we
don't know anything and we just want you
to times have changed you know you're
right and it's like times have not
changed people are still people and we
can see things from a different
perspective and like you think she wants
you to fail
even with all her passion and things
even with that do you think she's
feeling this fiery because she doesn't
care no of course not because I think
it's a tough love it is good I think
sometimes sensitive love is also good I
think uh our society right now at the
moment we're on the topic of modern
women I think modern women need a bit
more sensitive because
I feel like with your last generation
your parents were really tough on you
and I think a lot of our parents for
example like my mum and dad was quite
tough on me but I think our generation
is starting to learn more about like
psychology and the more more about how
people actually feel and how people
should be treated so we've got a bit
more sensitive I actually I have a very
strong feeling on psychology I think the
more we learn about psychology you're
more crazy become I think yeah do you
think yeah I say this I'm in getting my
masters in Psychology yeah not because I
want it but because I needed a Visa so I
thought it would be easy to be honest it
kind of is
programs crazy I'm not saying their
exceptions but literally they're all
nuts literally insane yeah
um I think but I don't I actually
disagree with you I think that we need
more tough love I don't think anyone I
don't think we everyone lies to women
whenever men tell us what they want we
Society lies to us and as I said body
didn't say that what she said did she
say need to be more sensitive to Modern
women I was like yeah she said yeah I
did say no no I did say that she said
you need to be mostly absolutely that's
what I said I said we need to be tougher
yeah no but she yeah
she wants you to be more sensitive yeah
listen can I ask you a question so this
happened at 17 years old yeah and how
old are you right now I'm 21. okay seven
three uh four years ago three four years
ago yeah um do you still consider
yourself I think a victim of them no I
consider myself for someone who survived
it and somebody that um
like I feel like I could have done a lot
of things better I could have left a lot
of times when I didn't leave but I felt
like
I was just sort of sucked into like a
cycle
where I felt like I couldn't get out
can I just say something young lady
right what you need to do right is say
to yourself I'm a Survivor I'm not a
victim
no I'm serious you see what I mean do
you see what I mean yeah it's not a game
I'm not joking I mean to be four years
outside of the situation happening and
it's still drawing tears out of you no I
mean like you know it ended recently as
in like it started about why were you in
it but you were in it for four years as
an adult and you didn't remove yourself
from the situation yes and again like I
said it's a mistake that I made that's
why you need more tough love because
you've gotten pandered to you've gotten
coddled through it that's why you stated
I didn't necessarily get cuddled because
again the only people that I was seeking
you needed a father to step into this
situation and say what are you doing
because obviously he's obviously not
into you he's obviously doing he's
obviously right but that's tough love so
you don't need more of bit this you
don't need more babying you need someone
to step in and say this is this is what
a man is this is how a man should act
and if he is not
that version then you need to stop you
need to go somewhere else
model women today have been lying to and
here's the thing is that like you guys
want us to be truthful but at the point
that we're truthful then you start
crying then you start you know with the
victimhood then you start with these
type of things so it's so often times we
just let y'all just go off
we just let y'all just do your thing and
then again you're going to be single for
the next couple of decades with a low
level barometer hate for men okay I
don't hate men personally can I ask you
something
to hit you is that what would happen
um I'd say it was a bit less physical it
did get physical a few times but
um by just him emotional or was it
two-party
um mainly him no but but you hit him too
on one occasion I hit him back yes
uh I did and I never actually pressed
charges one of them because at the time
I
still loved him which is it sounds a bit
weird a lot of people don't understand
that concept
but I was I genuinely still loved him
even though
it happened she went on do you think
that person charges on him is a
component of tough love or it's a
component of being cuddled um I I think
it's more of a component of me being
um sort of a empathetic person
empathetic person I tried to see the
good in people even when they've done
bad because I've done bad things and I
still believe I'm a good person so I
believe that other people are good yeah
they do bad things and I feel like I
if I
say for example I press charges on him
like he had a daughter as well if I
press charges on him that's not just him
going to prison but what if he hits her
that's I know exactly and that's another
argument I could be stopping over people
from going through that but I've because
again like I said I loved him at the
time I thought of it as like I'm not
gonna affect that okay if I get him
arrested it's not only just him that I
obviously I care about him I don't want
him to be in prison it's his child that
is going to be affected and then it's
just like a knock-on effect and I'm
curious
um I'm assuming when you guys were
together you didn't think you were
groomed right no I no so when did that
switch for you when did you decide you
were groomed when I I didn't this I
wouldn't say I decided I was grooming
well you changed your mind on it yeah
I'd say it like when I left the
relationship I started reading a few
books and I started like looking into
like new things
um well he's currently 28. if he was 22
would have been growing if it was the
exact same situation I mean the thing is
I feel like you can get you can sort of
get groomed at any age
no if he was younger than you would have
been grooming no um
see I'm going to be careful on what I
see here because I don't want to say
that no I don't want to say that but I
just feel like I don't want to speak too
much on the situation because obviously
this is going to be out there and I've
got people that are watching and whatnot
so I don't want to speak too much on it
but I
I knew this guy from when I was 15 he
emailed me a lot and then he'd sort of
buy me gifts button me up tell me that
he'd be watching me in work when I was
like 16 and like that and then just
sort of I don't want to say force me in
a relationship but well he did enforce
you in a relationship like I at the time
I thought I wanted that relationship and
then afterwards I seen all the signs of
like what he had done and how he had
gone about it and it it all lines up to
like grooming my opinion anyway are
there things are willing to call out
that um are specific to grooming as
opposed to just being a bad relationship
with someone consider abusive no
um there's a lot of specific things
obviously I'm not sorry for
swimming but I'm not like psychologist
um and I'm no and the reason why I ask
is because I think uh men today and
again I don't know your situation at all
I'm just talking in general a lot of men
today have words that are weaponized
against them when they were just bad
guys
one of the big ones is toxic masculinity
yeah you know um because I am you know I
have shitty components within my
masculine it is therefore toxic right
and it's a word that's kind of
weaponized and then there's kind of this
bad branding that Trails them no matter
what and you know
um two people again I don't know the
situation but there's people that are
watching that know you and that know him
and now they have a thought in their
mind that he's a groomer so that's why I
ask is to no the thing is it's most of
the people that I spoke to about the
situation that told me that like I
didn't realize until I had actually
because I when I'm in a relationship I
tend to keep a lot of things to myself I
feel like I it's between me and that
other person it's nothing to do with
anyone else there may be a few issues
here and there where I may seek advice I
may not exactly follow that advice but I
may just ask for other opinions and
again somebody said before there was red
there may have been red flags I ignored
and yeah again I'd say there was a lot
of red flags that I ignored but because
I was so willing to commit to this man I
decided to stay in that relationship and
endure what I endured because I thought
I loved this person but in reality I
felt like I was sort of
he
ah
I don't really know what to say anymore
yeah
um like for me
I see where you're coming from
everything because you know I think a
lot of people have gone through these
things and they don't actually know
they've gone through grooming but
sometimes like some people will suss out
your sorry um they will kind of evaluate
your situations and see how close you
are with your family or your friends and
things like that and that's kind of what
makes it groovin because it's like if
you're young and under the age of like
18 like 16 or so and they're 30 and they
know you don't have a good connection
with your family or maybe you even like
maybe were homeless or grew up in care
or things like that and then they can
appeal to things that you need because
you've never had anyone that can maybe
come across as grooming so then you look
at yourself because to me like 15 is a
bit a bit like you know but
I don't know when I was 17 I knew what I
was doing yeah but I got 17 you know I'd
say you know what you're doing but what
business does a 27 year old man have to
do with it like a 15 16 17 year old I
mean is it 15 16 17 I mean it was when I
was 15 he was what he would have been 24
and then onwards from there wait he
started talking to you when you were 15.
yeah let's talk about how that's illegal
is that is that legal here it's
definitely illegal
the thing is it wasn't he was talking to
me in a sexual way it was in because
again like I said so it was like in a
friend friendly way but looking back I
felt like he'd bottom me up like he'd be
on my socials complimenting me like
saying like one day I'm gonna wife
you like that and I didn't see it
weird yeah like 15 16. yeah yeah that's
weird that's illegal and I I didn't see
all the time and I genuinely I don't
know
I the first few years it was obviously I
I got I got with him when I was 17. so
it's not like I got with him when I was
underage
I was like 17 18 when I actually got
with him and started dating him and
whatnot and again like you said Pearl
you know what you're doing that at that
age I don't I don't sort of say I don't
know what I was doing yeah but again I
feel like I was in a vulnerable position
and I got taken advantage of you you you
were unwilling to make wise decisions at
that age up to 17 or whatever the
situated and it ended up a year ago you
throughout that whole time you've been
you were incapable of making great
decisions
so what that does not need is more
coddling that needs tough love yeah can
I just say something right she was um
she was working
oh she was working I you were old enough
to work I have been in uni um I'm old
enough to work yes but I have recently
left jobs no I don't use all this
situation I mean when everybody's
talking about the age
when they got together all I heard was
they may at work yeah I was I was
working in a legal job cash in hand from
15 years old but that's what I'm trying
to say so all right then if I go to a
workplace if you and me are going to
work right and I see you at work I'm
obviously going to think you're an adult
because you're working I'm not making
excuses unless you told him I am 15. I
did tell him and he told me you look 21
and you're mature for your age does I
excuse it I don't think it does no I
don't say an excuse me just because I'm
working it doesn't it it's excuses I'm
not saying it excuses it no but that's
I'm not saying it excuses it and this is
what I mean about you and your modern
people they always want you to be so so
soft and when you're trying to find out
what happens they always want to blame
the men because you're not letting me
finish saying what I'm saying you were
there working illegally right so the
first thing the guy could have seen was
that you're under eight that that you're
of age because you're working so first
start whatever your background you know
you can work from the age of 15 16 as
long as you have a national National
Insurance number and your parents
did you have your parents permission yes
I did right so you had your permission
to work so why couldn't you have parents
permission if your parents gave you
permission to work why couldn't you go
to your parents and say this guy's
talking to me and I'm underage
yes ma'am when you were first talking
and as what I understood you was what
was first gonna say is that you can't
come out here and call a man a groom
unless you've got evidence for it
you can't cut my hair I tell somebody
something I got that I called somebody
like oh yeah I can turn around and say
my son doesn't abuse you know what
because everybody knows it's been out
there I've taken him to court it's been
out there I've got an injunction it's
been out there but you're gonna come on
there and you're gonna say all these
things happen and then you're gonna turn
around and say oh though
that's where the respect comes in I
haven't finished talking though and
that's the problem in modern women
and that's the problem because he was
trying to say the same thing you come on
there and you're saying them obviously
like you said the people know who he is
the people know who he is so as far as
they're concerned he was in a
relationship is now a groomer because he
is
a groomer out there without a police
record
out there who hasn't gone to court for
grooming her this is what I mean you're
speaking on something that you literally
do not
knowing
I am not the same
every issue
you said you didn't press charges out
there without any any subject or
anything to do with you charges
because if somebody does something and
you press charges it don't press charges
don't talk about the man don't talk
about him on social media because people
are going to be out there do you know I
want to go with my son I can talk about
it because we're about to go do you know
how many people commit crimes and do not
go to prison for it and those are the
people that should be talking about it
those are the people when they commit
crime what does that mean when they oh
then when they commit crimes if somebody
commits a crime against you and you
don't want to report it shut up about it
what if you just got snitch
then you deserve to get abused I said it
no I said it I said it and somebody's
abusing you and you know that the police
are going to stop you and you decide to
sit there and you don't want to say
nothing well then you ask for it no
that's because you could have done
something about it you could have done
something about it rather than being
snitch so you don't want to be a snitch
but you want to sit here and be abused
person
it's like it's like you're trying to
turn them up to me and see you right I
shouldn't tell you I shouldn't tell you
about it I shouldn't tell people I got
hit by your boss and I got brain damage
because it's a bad thing to say
something
we're just taking the bus it's cool it's
a little bit different than that because
it's three sides to every story he's
going to have his own explanations of
course if he was describe the situation
do you think he would describe himself
as a groomer no but it is immoral though
no it doesn't work it is it is a moral I
don't think you would I'm just a
four-year-old to go for a 15. just
because that just because
she's telling us based off yeah when she
was 16. see see he might he might then
say well I didn't know she was working
on a spot and I thought you had to be 18
years old
right and he doesn't have a platform to
talk about it but I don't know you right
of course so I could absolutely
that's the whole but the thing is yeah
this happened she's not the only one
who's done this like girls will come on
the show and this is why it was on the
list because girls come on the show and
it's the same story oh he abused me and
they're always with him for multiple
years it's never just one year like the
first time I got hit I left it's always
multiple years you could have your
reasons for doing that but to me if
someone's hitting me in the face I'm out
I'm getting the out of there that's
just me so you don't know so unless
you're in a situation
this guilt tripping is
I understand okay but and so then and so
then I asked did you file a police
report and oftentimes the answer is no
and so then we're going to a point where
she can say he did this this and this
you might have enough okay I don't know
talking about you okay I'm talking about
the point okay and so the point is that
many men get accused of crimes they did
not commit and when there is no evidence
and no police report I don't know your
personal situation but it's weird to me
that you were there for multiple years
and you didn't press charges and you
just continued to stay and get hit
because if someone hits me in the face
I'm going to the police but so me
personally I was enough for multiple
years
um it was about 17 to 21. no it was no
you said 15. no I'm saying he was
grooming me from 15 to about I was 17
years old and then that's when things
started getting and further on well I'm
telling you and so I'm not saying that
sorry no I know what you're saying is
again it reiterates my point before why
I got upset about the list because some
women turn around and say I've been
abused I've been great I've been this
I've been that and it makes the actual
victims look bad and the actual victims
not want to report it because you feel
like you're doing something wrong by
reporting it and especially if you've
got someone in the back of your 18 don't
report me I've got a daughter I don't
want this to go wrong I don't want that
to go wrong like you're you love this
person and this person is telling you
all sorts it's hard for you to do that
report it then why would you go around
telling everybody
it just came up in this situation no no
you're going to record it on a podcast
for everyone to listen to why don't you
report it to the police where change can
be ha can be had what's the police going
to do apart from putting on the sex
offenders list and give me a restraining
order
I have a restraining other girls out
there protect my grandchildren and her
his cousin and her sister and everybody
are all the other females out there
that's what you're doing when you report
something like that you're not thinking
about yourself you're thinking about the
whole everybody around you and everybody
around you you're protecting everyone
else once you let an offender go you're
leaving you can abuse everybody else to
the full extent of the law do you know
what I don't disagree that he's done
these things he needs to be held
completely and utterly accountable and
and this is how men think when they're
talking to you and when they hear these
stories like there's so many men that
have false that have had false
allegations against them like most men
know someone that was falsely accused
so this might be harsh deer but I'm
telling you when they listen to these
stories they're gonna they think oh
she she might be lying she might do that
to me because there's no evidence
and I've been falsely accused and a
police report was not filed because she
was lying she was lying okay
because she knows that if she filed a
police report and let's say he went to
court and went to Jerry it wouldn't have
stood up because it she completely made
it up out of thin air and the evidence
would not have shown exactly the things
that she was saying at that particular
Junction because her feelings made it
feel like something that happened or her
back was up against the wall in that
moment and I I everything that all of
you guys are saying right now it holds
weight it's validity to that and it it
it just brings us back to the topic of
women not being held accountable and
being able to go around saying whatever
that is not
saying that your story isn't true or
anything of that nature but personally
this is still very raw for you and a
person has to be in a place where they
are ready to hear the um valid points
that are being given right the wisdom
the ingenious sharing even the points
that Melody is saying about coming to
her and being a mentor but if you are
not in a place where you can receive
that because right now in the moment you
are still defending the situation even
though your heart isn't to defend it
your heart is defending your feelings
and emotions around it but it just ended
in in October we are not even six months
away from that and it is as they are
talking you are being triggered and you
are reliving each and every moment and
that's not to it's what What's Happening
Here is you're going back through it
you're defending that and it seems like
you are rebellious to them and giving
valid honest good feedback for you to
grow and I know you're trying to receive
that and it's coming off very attachful
to you and now you feel like you have to
defend yourself and you can't properly
receive the wisdom that is going forth
in the room because it's it's
retriggering you so I just want you to
sit with this as he's already mentioned
make sure sure you go back through this
recording and you listen to the points
in a place when you are ready to
properly receive from it because it's a
lot of things that are being said that
honestly if you if you from the right
perspective listen to it and hear it
you're going to recognize that this
actually was a red flag that what they
said is true and in in even what they're
saying right now about calling someone a
groomer without the proper evidence no
one's saying that he wasn't a groomer no
one's saying that that wasn't present
but in the state that we live in where
women aren't being held accountable and
they go around accusing men how
dangerous that can be without action
behind it and that is the only point
which is a very valid point it is the
reality that we live in and it sucks and
it is unreal and so women like yourself
who have a Justified situation have to
deal with that reality but you have to
deal with the accountability too where's
the action that comes with it right and
we it's not to say that in the moment
things couldn't have been different but
I just want you to sit with that because
as another woman on this couch I can't
relate personally to that but I
emotionally and empathetically I feel
for you right now and I don't want you
to feel like you have to continue
defending yourself because that's what
it is listen I'm all I'm saying is
personally I did not want to mention
this at all on this panel I feel like
this is something that's quite personal
and again like you just said it's
something that's quite fresh to me so I
feel like putting it out there right now
was probably not
the best thing for me table something
that I wanted to do and I think that is
again why I'm getting a little bit
triggered because like I said it's quite
fresh to me I've only just started
speaking off about it and whatnot and I
think just hearing the point of view
that other people are trying to say that
I'm chatting I think it is a bit
annoying because no
like that's why it sort of feels like
it's because obviously I'm not saying
yeah
I'm not so you can't receive it and it's
fine but I need you to realize where you
are right because even your response to
this is still defensive and it's it's
nothing wrong with that but you have to
sit in that because everything that went
forth today was wisdom and it is a
different perspective and it's
challenging you right now because all of
your emotions are trying to justify and
to protect you and what you went through
and while your emotions may have been
real in the moment in perspective in
time are they valid is that the reality
that paints the picture of the holistic
experience in that moment what you felt
and what you went through was it real
absolutely but when in the perspective
of time vision is 2020 hindsight is 20
20. when you look back on that and you
take these other factors and elements
that everyone has contributed to in this
room you will have a different
perspective but right now in this moment
you're not hearing it you are not
watching I'm gonna let her fit I'm gonna
let you talk because I think you keep
getting cut off no sorry I do genuinely
value all your opinions in there
obviously you you're all much older than
me obviously you've got more wisdom and
more knowledge and whatnot
um but again like I was saying earlier I
just sort of feel like
I'm being quoting quote unquote as oh
this is just a modern woman this is how
she is and this is and basically I feel
like I'm sort of being put in a place
where I'm being categorized in a place
where I cannot change if that's what
makes sense I don't know who said you
can't change no one said that but I just
feel like I have wife it's like one in
one ear and out the other like I
honestly I'm not my Auntie Jenny at
this point it's like one end out the
other Mama it's like well holy you know
what right you know the one thing that
that stood out to me is that it's only
been about six months it's never too
late to report it and the most the most
you know the one thing that she said
he has
a daughter
right remember that he has a daughter
that's what's getting to me
is that she said he has a daughter she
was a daughter she is Somebody's
Daughter
I never man's a groomer groomer groomer
groomer they don't care whose daughter
it is
thank you and it's never too late I got
ranked I reported it like two years
afterwards still got taken up you know
what because the evidence was there I
swear for God if I came across a dude
that I knew was a beaut was abusive and
it abusing his daughter I swear for God
oh man report like come on what we want
to talk about this point
it's not adding up to me